I've had this question in recent days
which is
why some people on the right
have exalted
a
British pimp why parts of the Christian
conservative American right have exalted
a British Muslim
pimp who seduced women and played with
their emotions to turn them into
prostitutes so that he could steal most
of the money
how that became I'm talking of course of
Andrew Tate and so my friend zubi
tweets out what got me thinking about
this my friend zubi tweets out
Andrew Tate has positively impacted the
lives of millions of young men
objectively if you can do better than do
better I am doing my best with my
platform talents and influence the pro
clutching and finger wagging is tedious
and disingenuous
I guess my question to zooby's
declaration here is
has he has Andrew rotate positively
impacted the lives of millions of young
men
how
because he told them to you know go out
and make some money or something go work
hard I
they say that Andrew Tate has moved on I
don't know much about Andrew Tate's
biography they say oh no it was years
ago 10 years ago he was a pimp but now
he doesn't now from what I've seen the
evidence is he's been pimping until
pretty recently they say well the
charges in Romania have nothing to do
with him being a big pimp and seducing
these women and selling their flesh and
I said well I don't know looks to me
like the charges have quite a lot to do
with that uh but let's say let's say
even he was doing this until a few years
ago two years ago I don't know whenever
it was but then he he converted he said
I'm done with this I Repent this was
wrong okay well then maybe like
chill for a little while you know if
you've been doing something that is
egregiously evil and scandalous and very
destructive to people not just people's
bodies but souls for years and years and
years and you've enriched yourself on
that then maybe you ought to take a
moment
process your supposedly major change of
heart maybe make some reparation try to
make some reparation with some of those
ill-gotten gains and then maybe come
back in a few years and explain
you know how you've seen the light
I haven't seen Andrew do any of that
so what does zubi mean I don't know I
admittedly I don't know Andrew Tate I
don't think he's the worst guy in the
world but
he's a degenerative for everything I've
seen about this guy is that he's a total
degenerate and if he's repented great
but I haven't
you gotta like take a pause there man
so what is what is it that he's done
obviously zuby's not saying it's good
that he's a big pimp that that's helped
with men's lives so what is it and then
it got I I think it got to the point
that I understood which is
Andrew Tate is an internet self-help
Guru and he's not just one who dispenses
good advice for free he charges people
or has charged people to be part of his
fake kind of Academy he says give me a
bunch of money and I'll teach you how to
be a big player and you know I'll teach
you how to be really rich and powerful
and pick up women and all this stuff
so he's
at best I think an internet self-help
Guru scam artist
which is not much better than being a
pimp and as a public matter it's
probably worse this is the and it's not
just Andrew Tate I know I'm beating up
on Andrew Tate here there are so many of
these guys and so many of these online
Guru scammy artist type people
are either useless they might sincerely
believe they're helping but they're not
or their frauds they're just deceiving
people to get money to pretend they're
selling but it's this stuff is always
snake oil and the reason it's always
snake oil is there is there is one way
to improve yourself
and the way to improve yourself
and there's a natural component and a
supernatural component the natural
component is to practice virtues and to
stop practicing Vice and the
supernatural component is to accept the
grace of God and your lord and savior
who took on flesh and dwelt Among Us
that's it that's the only self-help book
you will ever need is the Bible
and
the books that have come out of the
Bible
and the religious tradition that
compiled the Bible and Remains the bride
of Christ the Living God that that's it
that's the self-help and all these other
guys who try to do it who try to divorce
God from goodness who try to divorce
religion and morality from
self-improvement they're always going to
leave you high and dry this is why it is
the I mean my my most miserable friends
in New York and LA are the ones who have
read the most self-help books
I just don't see it man how does that
positively impact the lives of millions
of people
huh
let's see it's kind of weird right now
go to
geniusell.comyt did you know our friends
at geniusell have upgraded their most
popular package to feature their top
selling deep firming vitamin C serum
plus Ultra retinol moisturizer with
natural retinol alternative right now
you can take advantage of this limited
time package upgrade for 70 off 7-0 why
waste time and money to get work done to
your face when you can get geniusell
skin care shipped straight to your door
here is a geniusell.com review from
Robert and blessing Texas quote I
purchase Jenny sells a gift for my
girlfriend she said she saw results so
fast her skin is noticeably softer and
smoother I can see and feel a difference
too she was already beautiful and
geniusell has made her more beautiful
geniusell secret is a family recipe for
over 20 years that makes it safe for all
skin types and perfect for both men and
women it's made by a compounding
pharmacist and small batch is always
safe cruelty free and natural the
founder of this company great guy Coptic
Christian from Egypt left for the
American dream head on over to
geniusell.com knowlesyt letter y letter
T try Jenny cell's most popular package
for 70 seven zero percent off featuring
both geniusell's Ultra retinol and
Geniuses Firming Serum get a
complimentary Spa Essentials box with
every package order plus free upgrade to
priority shipping geniusell.com
knowlesyt genucel.com Knowles YT former
Democrat mayor was just caught with
child pornography this is Patrick wojon
he's the Democrat ex-mayor of College
Park Maryland he pled guilty to 140
counts of child porn possession and
distribution in a deal that stipulates
the former politician serve
three decades in prison
uh I could very easily make jokes about
the Democrats all being pedos and how I
could point out that maybe this this is
more pronounced on the left and I
suspect it is but
I don't want to be a hack okay so I'm
going to observe yeah sometimes
right-wingers get caught in weird sex
stuff including in in this which is
about as egregious as it could possibly
be child pornography child exploitation
and it's not just the atheists sometimes
it's religious people and it's not just
the politicians sometimes it's I don't
know people thread all of society okay
it's
very pervasive my main takeaway from
this issue is I strongly suspect that
this
problem is much more widespread than
people want to admit
and I had that hunch so I just Googled
it I said what is the prevalence of
child pornography
one of the first results that come up is
from a group called the demand project
here's what it says child porn is one of
the fastest growing crimes in the U.S
nationally there's a 2500 percent
increase in arrests in the past 10 years
that's according to the FBI the national
Center for missing and exploited
children reviewed 17.3 million images
and videos of child porn in 2011 that is
four times more it's an insane number
but for our purposes what matters is
it's four times more than they reviewed
in 2007. so in the span of four years
you get four times more child born
uh what psychologists have learned
apparently is that when someone becomes
addicted to child pornography they
progress
to younger and younger children and more
sadistic and extreme cases of of this
stuff which of course makes sense
because that's how all pornography works
because that's how all addiction works
because it's you start out with a little
puff on the devil's lettuce and pretty
soon you're smoking you know the uh the
hunter rocks out of a glass tube on Skid
Row
is that you you either
break addictions and bad habits or they
get more and more extreme 2006 this is
all according to the demand project
I assume there are many other sources on
this it's literally the first thing I
clicked on 2006 U.S attorneys handled
82.8 percent more child porn cases than
they had in 1994 huge increase obviously
an estimated 50 000 50 000 people in the
United States are believed to quote be
consistently trading illegal images
involving children at any one time at
any one time 50 000 people consistently
dealing in this stuff
and furthermore 63 of teens said they
know how to hide what they do online
from their parents so a lot more those
are just the bullet points that jumped
out at me which tells me yes this guy
this Democrat mayor of College Park man
I he is God into some dark stuff and it
doesn't exonerate him in any way and um
but I don't want to especially knock him
because this is also obviously a
political problem it's not just the
cultural well we've got to Route the bad
guys out there's obviously a political
problem here how do you explain those
numbers increasing
we've talked about this with other
ideologies that we're not allowed to
mention on big Tech certain identity
ideologies that have exploded in recent
years
three times the rate of identification
with certain sexual ideologies in in
recent years you say okay well that
can't just be an individual problem
that can't unlike it can't even just be
an environmental problem unless there's
something in the water turning the
freaking frogs gay that's obviously got
to be a pervasive cultural and political
problem
it's a technological problem
why did the numbers Spike from the 90s
to the 2000s do you think it has
something to do with the internet coming
around yeah obviously
how could you fix this then
you could shame these people yeah good
you could
I don't know I don't know how you shame
them more it's already the most shameful
thing you could possibly imagine I think
you need to regulate this stuff
and you say well the child pornography
is already regulated yeah but the
internet largely isn't and pornography
generally isn't at all
it's not regulated at all the American
people have tried to regulate it on
multiple occasions Republicans and
Democrats child online protection act
and the communications decency act in
the 90s and early 2000s passed with
majorities and signed into law by
Democrat president
then liberal judges shoot it down so now
you've got to the point where the the
porn stuff is basically unregulated
well if you if you only focus on this
most egregious horrific version of porn
you're probably not going to catch it
numbers are going to keep growing if you
however
cut off the main supply of people who
get into the funnel where eventually I
guess it could lead to this stuff
I think you're gonna have much more
success
and what's going to be required there is
a less liberal view of
porn and
speech even I don't think obscenity is
speech but you're not you're gonna have
to have a more illiberal view and say no
you're just not allowed to look at this
stuff and it's going to choke off the
industry and big porn is terrified of
this this is why big porn just we'll get
to the story Tomorrow there's gonna be
my little tease for tomorrow big porn
PornHub and its parent company mindgeek
just cut off Arkansas this is just the
latest state to be cut off from this
porn website because Arkansas insists on
verifying people's ages and big porn is
so afraid of age verification that they
would rather shut off their service in
that state than comply with the law
what does that tell you it tells you
they're trying to hook people when
they're very young just like any drug
Peddler on the street and they know that
children that minors are very important
to the way the whole business operates
so you're not gonna you're not gonna
this is my somewhat Vindication of
Andrew Tate or not really I'm just
trying to be a little softer on them
you're not going to stop this problem by
just going after the random mayor in
College Park Maryland you're not going
to stop this problem by getting some
low-level webcam Pimp Like Andrew Tate
you're going to stop this problem by
arresting and imprisoning the CEO of
mindgeek the owners of the the biggest
porn companies in the world and shutting
off the service that's how you're going
to get serious about it as long as we
don't do that as long as we pretend
there's some Civil Right to look at smut
or something
the problem is only going to get worse
and those numbers are going to continue
to explode by multiples and Orders of
magnitude boy what a great clip that was
now make sure that you ring that Bell
subscribe to Michael Knowles YouTube
channel
see you next time